the whole season of season eight of
Smallville Davis Bloom uh which we were
well received and you know they offered
you a part in the next season to play
and you're like no the audience it was
doomsday uh uh I was doomsday in season
eight and then they wanted me to play
Zod since season nine and you're like
the audience won't believe it I'm not
doing it yeah which is ballsy it's it's
and by the way they didn't pay you a lot
they kept you as a recurring no no you
remain because I've never seen season
eight because I left in seven yeah so
now that we're doing talk film you're
gonna see your whole performance oh
Jesus Jesus well just know that that you
were a major building block in that
because no I well no no because I had to
study what you did to see what's
possible on the show and I was like oh
the answer is a lot the answer is you
can do a lot on the show because you
were going for it I mean I was and I I
was just so I was paying special
attention to your role not also because
I knew that I had to do something
different because I'm like I can't
and if I cover the same ground as
Rosenbaum performance wise
um that's not gonna win well it's not
you it's not me right and and and he's
already done it and he won he did it you
know everyone loves that character so
I've got to do something totally
different so I but but watching what you
did uh was a huge thing that convinced
me to do the the job because they were
sniffing around me for I don't know why
but they were so it was really a do you
want to do it or do you not want to do
it and watching your performance
convinced me no I think I want to do it
because you can look look what he did
look what he did so thank you yeah well
and which is a good thing because that
led to Being Human same casting director
and they were like in in Smallville my
character's kind of a monster who didn't
want to be a monster and being human is
a slightly more comedic version of that
a vampire doesn't want to be a vampire
and the casting return eventually was
like I think I know a guy who does this
because I had a lot of practice on
Smallville but just not the funny person
so from your performance and that you
got hey